invité de ce 19 20 le ministre de la
défense hervé morin bonsoir rama yade à
l'instant disait qu'on ne pouvait pas
arrêter l'opération malgré les doutes
pourtant le l'armée française étaient
sur place
elle ne pouvait réellement pas
intervenir l'armée française intervient
dans un état souverain
elle va bientôt déployé ses forces dans
le cadre d'une opération européenne
décidée aux nations unies et l'armée
française dans cette opération à
effectuer exactement la même chose
qu'elle fait avec toutes les
organisations non gouvernementales
humanitaire qui interviennent dans l'est
du tchad
il y a entre 75 et 80 ong organisation
non gouvernementale qui interviennent
dans cette partie du monde
le l'armée française puisqu'elle y
effectue en permanence des opérations
humanitaires apporte son soutien
logistique à toutes les ong qui sont
légalement sur le territoire national et
à aucun moment les militaires sur place
ne se sont dits à quelque chose qui ne
va pas et cette opération est anormal
non nous avions lorsqu'il ya eu la
première demande de children rescue
puisque arche de zoé s'était transformé
en tilt drones dans rescue en arrivant
au tchad
lorsqu'il ya eu la première demande
d'intervention pour le transport de
trois personnes
l'armée française a utilisé la même
procédure que d'habitude c'est à dire
qu'elle a obtenu le papier du ministère
de l'intérieur tchadien autorisant lo ng
à circuler sur le territoire tchadien
pour mener des opérations humanitaires
au profit d'enfants soudanais réfugiés
ensuite l'armée française a consulté
l'ambassade pour obtenir l'autorisation
et l'opération a été menée une première
fois pour transporter trois personnes
puis la deuxième fois pour transporter à
la demande de children rescue des
médecins des infirmières des pompiers
volontaires qui était dans l'avion et
pour transporter du fret qui était du
fret humanitaire
je complète par ailleurs après ces deux
opérations qui ont lieu en août et en
septembre
children rescue était sous tente
du haut comité aux réfugiés intervenez
toutes les semaines dans le cas des
briefings du hr du haut comité aux
réfugiés et donc rien ne permettait aux
à l'armée française de suspecter que
cette ong qui avait toutes les
autorisations d'un état souverain et
indépendant qu'est le tchad qu' il y
avait autre chose derrière tout cela
hervé morin dès le début la france a
condamné de manière très ferme les
agissements de l'association aujourd'hui
la priorité est ce que c'est pas de
soutenir ses ressortissants français
malgré tout vous avez entendu le
président a un public qui a dit qu'il
allait tout faire pour faire en sorte
que les choses se passent bien que
personne ne perde la face je crois que
ce sont les mots qu'il a employés pour
que c'est le rôle de la république
française de faire en sorte qu'à la fois
s'il y a des accords comme vous le dites
qui permette que ses ressortissants
soient j'ai choisi il faudrait qu'ils
soient jugés en france vient il faut
laisser la diplomatie française faire
son oeuvre
ce que je refuse totalement c'est qu'on
met en cause l'armée française qui je me
permets de vous le signaler et a depuis
le début de l'année 2007
transporté pas moins de 60 tonnes de
matériel au profit des organisations
humanitaires dans l'est du tchad est
transporté pas moins de 110 tonnes au
titre du programme d'alimentation
mondial au profit aussi des réfugiés
deux soudanais et donc considérer que
l'armée française et les militaires
français qui ont fait leur travail
qu'ils ont respecté les procédures qui
avaient l'autorisation de
du ministère de l'intérieur tchadien que
ces militaires français soit aujourd'hui
mises en cause
vous me permettez de considérer que tout
ça n'est vraiment pas digne juste d'un
mois on a pu entendre aujourd'hui la
gauche craindre une affaire similaire à
celle des infirmières bulgares si ces
personnes devaient être jugé au tchad
je crois que c'est pas la peine de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu nous avons
des relations avec le président tchadien
débit le président de la république a
indiqué qu'il allait mettre en oeuvre le
la diplomatie française pour faire en
sorte que personne ne perde la face
ce couac il faut éviter de faire dans la
surenchère et de faire dans
l'exploitation une affaire qui a somme
toute
avant tout une affaire malheureux et
triste triste pour les enfants et et
malheureuse pour les hommes et les
femmes qui ont participé à tout cela en
sachant qu'on ne connaît pas quelles
sont les motivations profondes qui les
ont amenés à faire cela merci beaucoup
et hervé morin forcé à précision